Thank you very much. I'm very honored to be here thanks to Yasu-san.
As he kindly introduced, I am a shinto priest at Meiji Jingu.
Although I'm just wearing a suit and tie like a business man.
And not cool with it at my office.
I'm standing at the far end of IT technology in this room, definitely.
But one thing I can say is, I've been using Gmail for many years.
I'm very nervous today since I have to make a presentation in English.
Especially I'm going to talk about Japanese culture and religions.
Both fields have a lot of difficult terms to translate
and my English is not good enough to deal with it.
Yasu-san, you're responsible for helping me, OK?
So before starting my presentation, do you know something about shinto?
Don't be shy.
Yes, please.
I'm Japanese, so I know more than 80% of Japanese people practice shintoism, some form or another.
It is to celebrate the royal family, and Ise Jingu is the main shrine.
Thank you very much.
Right. ?? still common I suppose.
OK, have you ever been to Meiji Jingu before?
Wow, thank you very much for coming!
So this is a picture of Meiji Jingu.
So you can see Tokyo Metropolitan buildings right behind Meiji Jingu.
So this area is called "nai-en" in Japanese.
And "in the precinct" in English.
Where is the outer precinct then, do you know?
The outer precinct in Japanese is "gai-en".
So you should know Aoyama Gaien.
Ah, yes! Gaien!
So this is inner precinct, the shrine precinct.
And this area is called "gai-en", outer precinct.
And there is a Meiji Memorial Picture Gallery.
And you can see the baseball stadium over there.
And the national stadium, or rugby stadium.
The national stadium, rugby stadium are not our property
But the inner and outer precincts are the property of Meiji Jingu.
And the Memorial Picture Gallery is famous for ginko trees in autumn.
So...
Please look at this picture. You can see the green belt here.
Do you know what this is?
This green belt.
Yes! Omotesando.
"Omote" means "main", and "sando" means "approach to the shrine".
So this street also has an important history
because this street was created at the same time as Meiji Jingu in 1920.
So a historical meaning
but as you know, there are a lot of brand shops.
Of course they are all welcome, but it's just distant from my life.
So you can see the green at the shrine precinct.
So this is a picture of new year's day at Meiji Jingu. A lot of people visit.
A few million people visit this shrine in a few days or a week from new year's day.
This shrine was founded in order to dedicate to the spirits of emperor Meiji and Shoken.
However, there are no relic, dead bodies or statues
of the emperors are would be expected at the shrine.
And do they come to Meiji Jingu to revere the spirits of emperor Meiji and Shoken?
Probably not, because...
they do not know what is enshrined at Meiji Jingu.
Here are some statistics.
The population of Japan is 125 million.
Among them, as she said, about 91 million are are shinto followers.
And almost the same as buddhists.
And for example the christians are 3 million.
You laughed because you added the two numbers, right?
It exceeds the population of Japan.
But if you ask any Japanese what is their religion
The answer is most probably, "I have no religion".
Many Japanese are nodding.
Then why do people visit shinto shrines in the cold weather of new year's day?
That's crazy, isn't it?
I'd better talk a little bit about the environment of Japan first.
The land of Japan is surrounded by the sea
and 70% of the land is mountainous.
And a lot of rivers, lakes and small islands.
Thanks to the four seasons,
from spring, summer, autumn to winter,
we receive a lot of blessings such as fish from the sea,
or vegetables from the mountains, fields and so forth.
That is why we show our gratitude to nature.
On the other hand, Japan is also famous for natural disasters
like typhoons, tsunami or earthquakes.
We pray not to have these severe natural phenomena while showing gratitude to nature.
Our ancestors may have thought natural disasters were raised because they disturbed the harmony of nature by their living ways.
Therefore, they tried to keep the harmony of nature by finding themselves as a part of nature.
Shinto has been formed based on these two minds: grateful and awesome feeling towards nature.
We join our hands like this to the sun or to the sea, or to the rivers.
Those objects are called "kami" in shinto.
Kami of the sun, kami of the sea, or kami of the mountains.
Monotheistic religions have only one omnipotent God, but shinto has thousands of God, or "kami".
So there are one or several enshrined kami at each shrine, but none of them seem to be idolized.
Instead people are greeting various kami, or kami in general, when they visit the shinto shrine.
So in this sense, it's not that strange even though the visitors do not know what is enshrined at Meiji Jingu.
So if you think of religion as a means by which we can find salvation through following God's commandments,
living righteously and repenting,
it will be difficult to understand the nature of the shinto faith.
Shinto has no founder.
Shinto has no founder, holy scriptures or concept of conversion.
So there is no single accepted definition of shinto.
But let me try to explain my view of shinto from two aspects.
That is connections with God and connections with societies.
As far as I understand, Monotheistic religions attaches importance to connections with God.
Because an omnipotent God created this world and mankind
and mankind can live under God's protection and can attain peace after death.
To stay connected with God, we need to follow God's will strictly.
Because of this strictness
deep faith in God is developed,
human ethics or religious body are upheld,
and happiness and peace are maintained, I think.
So there is another aspect of religion that is connections with societies.
When we see someone facing difficulties
we try to help them to overcome their hardships through a variety of methods and actions.
I am grateful for the help from the world when the big earthquake and tsunami happened 5 years ago.
Whether it is love, charity or mercy,
religious values provide people with a clear path towards sharing happiness with each other in the context of social relationships.
If connections with God place more emphasis on individual pursuit of peace after death,
then connections with societies orient people towards achieving happiness not only for themselves but also for the many people in this life.
As I mentioned before, our ancestors thought that we are surrounded by many kami,
even kami of our ancestors.
This world is filled with kami.
You might notice that the concept of kami is quite different from the concept of God.
In shinto, connection with kami and connections with society are integrated.
Shinto believes that people receive blessings from countless kami surrounding them.
And in the course of their lives, they receive energy for their own development or societal growth.
In Japanese there is an expression, "Ikasarete-iru". Do you understand the meaning of this?
Ikasarete-iru.
It's quite hard to translate into English, so I'm not sure if I can explain this accurately.
But let's take an example:
Instead of saying, "I live by eating rice",
we would say, "I'm allowed to live by the rice,"
which assumes the idea that rice is a blessing that we must be thankful for
as the efforts of many people went into its cultivation.
Based on the magnificient working of the sun, rain, soil and microorganisms,
and furthermore, it was harvested and transported, and placed on store shelves.
"Itadakimasu", the phrase before eating with joining our hands together,
has all meanings of our thankfulness.
So individuals are "ikasarete-iru" through various interactions in society.
It means that individuals also have an effect on these interactions.
In my opinion, the reason that Japanese people cherish harmony
is because they recognize this interconnectedness, consciously or unconsciously.
In principal, an individual's happiness equals peoples' happiness.
Many people are mindful to behave in a way that maintains progress of harmony in the context of this interconnectedness.
I perceive this as shinto's sense of religious value.
I found an interesting expression in the book "Angels and Demons" by Dan Brown. Have you read this book before?
No? But you've watched the film of "Angels and Demons"?
Is that this old?
No?
No? Everybody?
Nobody?
Yeah, "Angels and Demons".
OK, anyway, in that book there is an interesting phrase:
"The planet is an organism. All of us are cells with different purposes."
"And yet we are intertwined. Serving each other. Serving the whole."
Don you think this is an interesting expression?
So in addition, there is a concept called "Jo-Mei-Sei-Choku"
Meaning "pure, bright, honest and sincere."
Which is also an important value in shinto.
So by maintaining purity and sincere heart
a peaceful and happy social environment will be achieved.
Purity means dislike of "kegare", or "uncleanliness."
Kegare links to the term meaning the dying up of one's life force.
In this state, we cannot unleash our potential energy.
So please look at this as the potential energy that a new born baby has like the sun.
However day by day, impurities approach it,
resulting in weakening its original vitality.
So in order to get rid of these impurities, shinto has purification in many ways.
For example in bathing water like this.
Or like this.
This is a picture of Meiji Jingu.
We have this "misogi" or "bathing water" in the cold days of January.
And you wash your hands and rise your mouth before entering the shrine.
And at the end of June and December we have big purification ceremonies like this.
The shinto priest using a wand to cast away the impurities or uncleanliness.
So by doing so
we regain the original energy and vitality to live.
The Japanese peoples' love of bathing is also one example I think.
Here again I quote a phrase from "Angels and Demons" by Dan Brown:
"God, Buddha, The Force, Yahweh, the singularity, the unicity point"
"Call it whatever you like, the result is the same."
"Science and religion support the same truth - pure energy is the father or creation."
I think this is also interesting.
So restore an individual's vivid state
the support from society, as well as the efforts of the individuals become important.
The shinto rituals, or "matsuri", may play roles to enforce this vitality.
Have you joined any matsuri before?
Some of them, right? People are very crazy for joining matsuri like this.
Or this one too.
A lot of people are watching too.
And these ladies. This is Awa Odori at Shikoku islands in Tokushima prefecture.
And even the children are involved in these matsuri.
They look very vivid I think.
So beside these big ritual ceremonies
small rituals or customs can be seen in our life cycle events.
Like bringing a new born baby to a shinto shrine.
Or seven, five, three year old children like this.
And coming of age day.
So these are important opportunities for us to clean up ourselves, or to show our gratitude for the growth,
and to feel we are living in the community of this world.
Personal happiness, society's happiness, is to evolve the existing harmony into a more progressive harmony.
If I can say, our mission in this life will leave behind a even more harmonious world for future generations,
while inheriting the harmonious world our ancestors have created.
Many Japanese people live by sensing the horizontal connections with societies
coupled with vertical connections with life, connections with past and future.
Here is a question however: Is this only limited to shinto or Japanese?
What I have mentioned is just the idea of consideration for other people.
I believe this is a universal value that cuts across all religions, or all over the world.
Nowadays, a lot of foreigners visit Meiji Jingu
on weekdays almost all foreigners I can see.
So they come to Meiji Jingu where there is nothing such as buddhist statues or sacred relics or national treasures to see.
But the visitors seem to feel refreshed and regain their energy for their growth.
And I am always moved when I see tablets hung around the trees here in front of the main shrine building.
So look at this:
You cannot figure out which languages are written, but...
you can see Thai, English, French, Chinese, or German...
There are many languages written. And look at this:
"I am grateful for all the love and gifts with which I have been blessed since my life began."
"I now ask for strength and support to overcome the health challenges before me,"
"for a full and complete recovery and for health and happiness for myself, and the family who I love."
It's a beautiful prayer.
One more thing:
"With appreciation and gratitude for all of my many blessings:"
"family and health and business success"
"and the many wonderful people in my life."
"Please guide me to continue to appreciate these gifts"
"and share my good fortune and plenty with others in this world."
"The world is full of infinite possibilities!"
Nice words and they very naturally express their gratitude to many things,
and extend their warm hearts to others.
So thank you very much for your attention, this is my short presentation.